cool thank you very much for the
introduction thank you all for being
here and as the title States I would
like to talk a little bit about Russ
with you but uh doing it in a
programmatic way so don't expect too
much like high level Tech or like Cool
Tech this will be really down to earth
hopefully
and maybe a little bit about me I'm a
physicist by training and then
essentially started working as a data
scientist by now at Volkswagen and I've
been using python 5G quite some time now
and maybe to give you also a little bit
of a background why I really like python
is essentially this interactivity right
you can see the results of what you're
doing when you're building a model when
you're analyzing data when you're but
also when you're writing tests for
example something I like to do and then
you can really see the outcome and then
iterate on that
however there's also a little bit of a
dark side to python I would say
specifically the python can be very very
slow if you're in particular like if
your data doesn't fit into numpy pandas
it can be slow and I think much more
importantly also it's really easy to
leave the golden path like you make one
wrong step and suddenly it becomes slow
and I think this is something that is uh
like a little bit tricky with python and
I would like to present you some
strategies of maybe using rust to get
around these rough edges
and the strategy will not be to replace
python I really like python python as a
cool language and for everything that is
interactive I think it's also unmutable
at least for me but rather I would like
to show you a little bit how to sprinkle
in Rust here and there and then how to
make your code fast overall and actually
I would say that Python and rust have
complementary strength where one is
really interactive really nice to like
play around with the others rather slow
and also in compile times if we saw it
this morning but then it's fast and the
other is a bit slower if you do maybe
non-standard stuff
so I'm a data scientist so what I
typically do is I start somewhere with
some kind of data let's call it complex
data think like a giant heap of Json or
PDF documents as we will see in a second
and then I typically want to put it in
the data frame
um as as we do as you do I guess and
then perform some kind of analysis on
top of it to build a model and maybe
already here like a like an advanced
notice so to say uh what you could buy
and can by now put in a data frame also
it's really much more complex than the
usual you have a string column you have
an integer column but with the arrow
format that we already heard a couple of
times in this conference you can do
really cool things in principle whatever
you can think of you can put by now on a
data frame so really data frame is more
than just a darker simple table
and specifically I would like to talk
today about two examples one is parsing
PDFs here I chose bank statements
because I have them available on my on
my laptop and then also how to convert a
type of Json files into a data frame
than to do analysis on top of and here
this is this Json data set by Spotify
the million playlist data set but we
will get to all the details in a bit
so and now I would like to show you a
little bit how you can use rust in these
two tasks and maybe some strategies
like a quick warning there will be rust
code ahead I don't expect you to be
familiar with rust so maybe you don't
get every single line my goal here is
more to give you some pointers and hints
and give you a feeling how it looks like
not that you understand every like I
said every single line so don't worry
hopefully it's kind of self-explanatory
and if not like sleep for 30 seconds and
then some python code will come again
so what do I like about rust uh so by
the clear the motivation here is like
for performance and memory efficiency I
want something that is fast and
efficient and rust delivers on that I
think there's also one of the main main
goals of when Ross was designed
the other thing is that I particularly
like about rust is that it's very easy
to integrate into other things it
doesn't have a run time it doesn't have
a garbage collector it's really built to
interface with anything that speaks cabi
in particular python as well so you can
use the same Rusk library in Java in
Python in goal and you don't it's really
easy whereas with for example something
like go you have a garbage collector
suddenly it becomes more complicated
um also I really like how rust is
designed it has some kind of features
that fit nicely together and form a
cohesive hole that you can use to build
really high level interfaces and I will
show you a couple of examples later on
and finally as we also heard this
morning with rust comes like great
tooling great documentation uh not every
library is well documented but overall I
would say the quality is very high in
particular of the core project
so this morning we heard about how to
use pile 3 to build essentially
something that you like some Rust
library that you can use in Python and I
would definitely say this is the gold
standard like if you want to build a
high quality package that you maybe want
to deliver to other people you should
definitely check it out I think that's
the way to go
and
um maybe sometimes if you check out some
open source package that you're using
and then you're interested how it's
built it may come to some surprise to
you that if you look at the source code
there's not a single line of python not
a single python file and pile three
really makes it easy to build pythonic
interfaces on top of your rust code
without writing Python and I think this
is really like a testament to the
library to the quality
and this is an example a very simple
example it's just from the documentation
essentially a function that takes in a
number an integer and then doubles it
and one thing that is very specific
about rust and that will come up a
couple of times later on is that rust
allows you to do code generation via
those macros so every time you see this
hash and a bracket or maybe something
with an exclamation mark this is code
generation where the compiler generates
code for you that you don't have to
write yourself and this also makes rust
very very nice to use and very uh very
first and very short
like I said we will not oh maybe I
haven't said this is up already but this
will not be about pile 3 actually
um I would rather want to advertise for
some hecky easy way specifically let's
build our own command line tools and
then interface with these command line
tools to get essentially the speed up
and as an example let's stick with the
whole doubling number thing so we have
this command line tool called IL
patterns minus double dot Excel so this
is the name is all from the repository
that is also on GitHub if your case are
interested and then the command line
tools takes the Json in with the value
and then returns another Json out with
the value doubled and why Json it's a
lingua francof data exchange I would say
everything speaks Json everything writes
Json so it's nice and easy
if you want to have a bit more
performance maybe go for binary encoding
and there are also options then to
generate the code that you need to
essentially go from A to B
when you want to use this tool from
python or this command line tool you can
use the built-in sub process module so
what you do is you call the command line
tool and then you need to configure a
couple of options importantly in Rust
every string is a utf-8 encoded so you
should set the encoding whatever is
encoding of your machine is
and then we want to get the output out
so you say capture output we want to
have an exception if an error occurs
check equals true and then we
essentially we have the last two lines
where we feed the input in and the
output out
and I would like to show you a little
bit how you can easily then write the
code for that so you get essentially
this encoding of the input and the
decoding of the output
and the basic strategy is to use types
and code generation both in Rust and in
Python and for example here I use data
classes depending on your choice maybe
you would or in your on your on what you
like you probably use something
different for me typically data classes
Works quite well from the standard
library and so here we Define our
essentially our interface as types
and then there's a very nice Library
called C address that gives you for the
simple cases a zero configuration way of
going from these data classes to
something that was Json compatible and
Back Again
if you are using unions so something
that could be a float on end then you
need to write a bit more code yourself
you will find some examples in the
repository of different coding schemes
but let's skip with a simple case for
now
so if you go from the way from python
object to a Json compatible objects so
to say you can use the unstructured call
so what it does it takes your data class
in and then essentially returns
something that is like plain old python
dictionaries and lists and then you can
use json.dumps to get essentially
something that is a Json string
if you want to go the other way around
you just use structure and essentially
you load your Json string then you
structure it into the output so you get
back your output data class that you
then use in your code so you do main
objects and that's essentially
everything you need for the python site
and all we did is essentially we needed
to write the type definitions the rest
is taken care of by the type pins
in Rust actually we do the same so here
we Define our types as well in this case
it looks a bit different because it's a
different language we have our
structures this is essentially the data
class parts and here we are again using
Code generation so everything with a
hash and we're using a library called
server for serialization deserialization
which is the de facto standard in the
rust ecosystem to essentially get types
serialized and deserialized and again
all the codes that takes care of
converting from Json to your types and
back again is generated for you
and then if you want to implement this
either or doubling interface what you
can do then is essentially you read from
standard in
and then build your rust object out
then you perform the operation in this
case doubling the number and then write
it back out to standard out that's it
and maybe to contrast let's say the two
ways like Pi or three or some other
bindings generator and doing it this
custom CLI tool way if you go player
three this is definitely the way to go
if you want to build high quality
extension modules also maybe ship
something put it on pipe bi I will
probably go this way uh also if you go
for maximum efficiency so if you want to
ring out every last bit of performance
this is the way to go however there's
also some drawbacks I think you need to
quite well understand how pile 3 works I
think you also need to understand the C
API because sometimes there are these
like rough cases where you actually need
to understand houses and translate it
into the C API in particular bugs
happened
um there's also this uh I would say
non-trivial building installation step
we've seen this morning that you can
just just use Maturin but still you have
this extra step where you need to build
something compile something and then
integrate it into your python
environment
one thing that is like a big drawback
for myself personally speaking you don't
have reloading so python extension
modules or native extension modules as
far as I'm aware cannot be reloaded so
for example if you use it in your
jupyter interpreter you have to kill The
Interpreter and start from scratch which
is essentially something that really
gets uh yeah I really don't like
when you go to the CLI array about
things I would say it's really easy to
get started you have like Json in Json
out you can inspect the results and if
something goes wrong it should be easy
to figure out
it's easy to build and distribute it's
much easier also to cross compile even
though rust is already great in Cross
compiling it gets even easier if you
build executables not shared libraries
however it's not very it's not super
efficient so you clearly have
performance overhead and also you don't
have shared memory or shared objects so
it's more for functional patterns
functioning input in output out
but you can always still refactor into
pile three if you want to go for more
performance
and after this little bit of explanation
I would actually show you how you can
use it and that even though it kind of
seems a little bit maybe too simplistic
or too simple up to simplistic it
actually can get out some nice speed
benefits from it
and the application specifically is
about parsing PDF files and I would like
to tell you a little bit about why PDF
files are actually a little bit tricky
for python so if you have this fake PDF
files I didn't want to show you my bank
statements what you see is essentially
for the bank statement of some German
bank and uh what you then see in the PDF
actually is instructions uh to some
abstract machine where it says something
like move the text position to position
one two and then at this position put
this text and this can then be combined
with like transformation matrices and
maybe with color changes and so on and
so on
and what you now need to be do is when
you want to like get the information out
of your PDF you actually need an
interpreter for the stream of commands
and this is here taken from the PDF
minor six Library a very nice library
but now you have this interpreter
running in an interpreter and this then
gets low so this is where you can get
the speed up
so what we will do is essentially we
will go from the raw PDF to
tuples or like some objects where we
have position and text fragments and
then we will use the second step to find
the header in the footer of the
transaction tables group the different
transaction items and then pass
essentially the date in the amounts
for the first part we will investigate
Python and rust whereas for the second
part this will always stay in Python so
essentially you have a very small part
of your python application that you
replace and the large but large part
will stay in Python SS actually as we
will see the Rust part is quite long
when I do that for a year of transaction
for one year of my bank accounts we have
essentially these two steps Step One is
something like 17 lines of PDF minus six
mostly getting the type definitions and
converting it into the types and then
you have something like 106 lines of
python to interpret the results and for
one year this took on my laptop
something like 25 seconds so you have
like 12 bank statements and yeah 25
seconds I would say that's not great
performance wise
for the rust side of things we replace
this first step with the command line
tool and then some interfacing tool
there we use the library called PDF
extract and what this looks like roughly
is you have this command line tool that
gets the bank statement or the PDF file
as an argument and then gives you also
station document and actually it's now
not a single Json document but Json
lines so multiple documents but the
general idea stays the same
and if you now run that and leave
everything else untouched you get a
speed up of a factor of 11. so just by
replacing this one little step and not
like
that I would say it's not overly
complicated to do it but you get a nice
decent speed up here
there are several a couple of caveats
here on the one hand uh I definitely
have to mention that PDF extract is
definitely less mature than PDF minor
six so for example in this Bank of mine
there's like this initial page where you
have this like hello Mr poem and so on
for example this is not passed at all
this is completely lost so whether this
is applicable uh it clearly depends on
on the PDFs you're using and also maybe
on the library more maturing
at the same time also the speed up you
get really depends on the PDFs you're
using in this case it's a very simple
PDF but in practice I actually observed
the factor of 60. so when you had
something like takes like hours you talk
about minutes and this is like really a
decent speed up so suddenly we didn't
need to parallelize because you could
just use a single core on a laptop and
do our data processing and uh so it
depends always a little bit on your use
case but in particular for PDFs I would
really recommend you to check that out
so let's get uh to a second step uh or
like a second use case uh specifically
about uh parsing Json files
and one thing I will be using here is
the arrow file format I think some
people have heard it already there were
some questions also in the in the
lightning talks channel for example and
maybe let's take a step back and explain
a little bit what the arrow format is
the arrow format is not a data format
for like a file format but rather it's a
way of arranging data in memory so
essentially it's a specification how you
structure your bits and bytes such that
different languages can use the same
data and if you look for example on the
official documentation you will find
bindings for C C plus plus and so on but
also Python and rust which are the two
libraries that we are interested in
and what is also really nice about Arrow
it does not only support primitive types
so something like strings integers
floats but you can really encode lists
you can encode structures maps you can
even encode unions in this data format
so in principle I would say everything
you can put down in in Python you can
probably also put down in in Arrow
whether you can then use it efficiently
in the library that's a different case
but at least you can put it into this
binary formative in the first step
and what also it's really nice is if
you're going the pile 3 route uh there's
really high level bindings also for that
in the arrow package itself so it's also
really easy to interface it and really
write efficient functions that take
Arrow data frames in and then give out
Arrow data frames out
maybe to give you a little bit of a
feeling how it looks like in practice
so consider you have two columns one
with integers nullable integers so some
items are missing and then maybe you
have some nullable text column let's say
hello world with a with a missing value
in between
and what Arrow does is essentially it
specifies how you structure a like
simpler arrays from it so for example
for the um for the integer array you
would essentially encode one array of
64-bit integers and then a second array
with a bit mask where it's essentially
the missing values are
and then for the strings you would
encode everything as you'd have eight
characters and then include essentially
another array that gives you the offsets
where the different string starts and
again another ability mask
and now the trick is because everybody
knows how to encode strings or all the
different libraries know how to encode
strings you can now use the same data in
pandas polars hugging faces using it for
the Harding face data sets I think Pi
torch is now using Arrow underneath and
obviously also in your own tools you can
use it and then essentially right arrow
and then put it into all these other
tools
so the use case here is essentially
parving uh like a Json document like a
heap of Json documents converted into
like an arrow file and then do some
analysis on top of it in Python the data
set in question is a million playlist
Spotify data set it's something like 30
gigabytes uncompressed 5.4 gigabytes
compressed and has essentially listings
of different playlists with artists and
so on and then you can ask what is the
most popular artist in this data set for
example
and when we compress it down into this
Arrow file format this is actually like
some intermediate format that is more
used for for internal exchange but you
can also use it with all the tools that
speak Arrow typically then we will
compress it down to 0.2.3 gigabytes
which is actually a nice data set that
you can either load in RAM on a normal
desktop or even you just use a memory
map and then use efficiently without
loading it at all
so when we do it in Python uh we again
this route of defining types and doing
this type definition way
we have the schema of the data set as I
said before you have essentially the
different playlist names and then you
have different columns in particular you
have this tracks column and this is
actually what I mentioned before you can
encode really those complex data types
so in this case for example we have this
list of dictionaries and in the
dictionaries here and you have artist
names and track Uris and other other
things
so how do we then convert it in in
Python to this Arrow format it looks a
bit unwieldy but I just saw that I have
enough time to walk you through it
slowly
so first of all you need to close it
individual Json documents I didn't
decompress the zip file but just use it
as is and essentially load the
individual Json Json blocks as I think I
think something like a 1000 playlists in
a file and then 1000 files in the
overall zip file
then there's a processing step which we
need to do because dates in Arrow are
actually encoded in milliseconds not in
seconds so we need to multiply by a
factor of thousand and then finally we
iterate over the different columns and
build out the individual arrays uh maybe
uh sorry in Arrow speak a table is a
data frame roughly and an array is a
serious roughly if you're coming from
pandas and one thing you may already
notice here that there are a couple of
Loops in in Python so first of all you
have this Loop over the playlist and
then you have this Loops over the
different columns first of all but
that's not the slow Loop but you also
have this Loop over the individual
playlist so essentially you Loop over
all the items I mentioned that already
here because surprisingly this is very
fast which is a shame for me later on
on the rust side of things we use the
same strategy as before we Define our
types then use code generation for the
types
and so all we now need to do is we need
to load the Json files and then convert
everything back to an arrow file
one thing I'm using here is the library
I've written called soda Arrow but there
are also other libraries around in
particular the main Arrow library has
now this feature also built in but the
main idea is to use the same code that
we generated for serialization
deserialization to also you build our
arrays that we can then essentially use
in our Analytics workflows so in
principle this is all the code of the of
the package of this like program there's
a little bit more but in principle
that's it
the operations are more or less the same
first of all we Loop over the individual
files and we load the Json document uh
the specifics are here Arrow specific
but in principle it's the same step uh
rust specific sorry but the principle is
the same step as in Python then we
iterate over the individual playlists
and perform this factor of thousand
conversion and then essentially we push
it into this Builder object to build our
Arrow arrays in Ram
and then we can write it to disk and
then use it for something like in polars
for example to do the analysis on top
so let's compare the different results
and as I said this will look a little
bit disappointing in the beginning but
we'll get to it that is a little bit
more exciting so bear with me so first
of all what you see there's not that
much performance difference from python
to rust and then also I plugged out this
part which builds the arrays manually
added something like 200 lines more of
code to build the arrays manually but
also that didn't really help that much
so if you go from python to the rust
implementation that I've shown you
before we have something like a factor
of 10 percent
and actually the only reason why it's
even faster is because we have this
multiplication by a thousand to be very
honest
um so if you have obviously more
transformation it becomes slower in
Python if you then build the arrays
manually you have something like a 60
speed up so it gets a little bit uh more
exciting
however I was kind of lying to you
because the big problem here is that the
python implementation actually doesn't
really help or doesn't work at all
because I have something like 16
gigabytes of RAM but the overall data
set is something like 32 gigabytes right
and so I can't fit it in Ram and I can't
really process it and the reason here is
or the issue here is that you have very
many repeated elements so one artist is
appearing in very many playlists and so
clearly this can be very much compressed
down and something that you can use here
is a technique called dictionary
encoding in Arrow or categorical
encoding in in pandas to really
essentially replace all these repeated
elements
and this is already done by the rust
side but not done by the by the python
side if you then Implement that in
python as well it suddenly becomes very
slow or not very slow but much slower
than before and suddenly you get a
decent speed up with with rust so you
have something like 2.4 if you are using
the lazy route and 3.3 if you build a
race manually
and this isn't really this overhead
where you have to send this like custom
string manipulations where you do
Dictionary lookups and suddenly a python
becomes slow
um one thing that's also maybe of
Interest here is if you just do the Json
parting in Rust and throw away all the
data you just go over the data set pass
the files and then count the playlist or
whatever so something very simple this
is more or less the whole runtime of the
program and this is actually why python
is also so fast because in principle
everything you're doing in the simple
implementation is you're loading the
file from disk you're doing the Json
parthing all of that is done in C and
yeah this is efficient so essentially
whether you use rust for that or python
doesn't really make a difference
I think you really get a benefit here
suddenly when you do something that is a
little bit more complicated and at your
own custom processing steps and then
suddenly you see decent speed UPS
without doing anything overly
complicated
so let me conclude
um I tried to show you a little bit uh
how to use rust for data processing at
least like a first glimpse of that
in principle rust is faster memory
efficient out of the box that's not also
always the case there are some simple
ways to shoot yourself in the foot but
overall the naive implementation is
already fast quite often
the big caveat here I think the Rusk
libraries in particular for data
processing are not as high quality as
the python ones so you should expect to
write mode more code yourself
for example for the PDF thingy if we
wanted to have the first page of the
bank statements probably we would need
to have to write our own
extraction library on top of the low
level PDF Library so clearly that's more
complicated
but in general I think everything should
be more or less there and uh yeah
hopefully also quality improves over
time
um I talked a little bit about different
strategies
um I think if you want to go for some
high quality extension module that you
want to share with the community you
should definitely go with pile 3 or some
other related binding package I would
still pick pilot 3 probably
um but uh what I hoped uh also to show
you is that quite often you can also get
away with something hacky just write
your own little command line tool uh
don't care about all this like
particular particularities of the C API
just do something Json in Json out or
write a file to disk and then use it in
your workflow
the general strategy always is
essentially use typins as often as
possible or type type definitions in
Rust and essentially generate most of
the code so it's really also easy to get
started and efficient to get going
and then if you're in this like more
small data regime so for the PDF case we
have essentially medium large files but
then we like extract a couple of words
so this is like something where the
coding is doesn't need to be efficient
we can get away with using Json
something like the Spotify playlist data
set where we have very many rows then
suddenly it makes sense to go in this
direction of using arrow for that
and finally some tips when to
incorporate Russ so first of all I think
performance benefits are not always
clear-cut so the story of I will add
rust and suddenly it's a factor of 10
can sometimes be the case but also uh
quite often it can't be it will not be
the case and the underlying sorry for
that the underlying reason is
essentially that lots of python
libraries already written in C and are
fast out of the box here the thing is
really if you'll essentially leave the
confines of these libraries and you need
to do something custom I think then I I
would investigate rust and look into
that as an option
in particular whenever you need to bring
something that is like in some weird
format I would count PF as a weird
format into something that is python
compatible I would definitely look into
uh into rust and the more processing
steps you have in their data pipeline so
even this little effect of a thousand is
already enough then suddenly uh doing
something in Rust becomes becomes viable
but if you just do load data put it in
another format I think probably rust
won't help you here
thank you very much and I would be happy
for any questions
[Applause]
thank you Christopher for your talk
unfortunately we are out of time for the
questions sorry I maybe it was
misleading about the indications but if
you have uh your questions we have them
on slido I recommend you to talk to
Christopher directly for your questions
and thank you for attending round of
apples again for Christopher thank you